hey guys happy whatever day it is today
so I'm gonna be vlogging a bit because
we are going on a little family trip
Jane excuse me I'm vlogging so we're all
packed up and ready to go I also want to
tell you guys before it's too late if
you guys want to get the October I just
Jean fancy box in the description so
hurry up and go get it if you guys want
to get it this month it's kind of crazy
because we picked out all kinds of
really fun October Halloween themed
bangs sure you guys have seen all those
cool subscription boxes if this one's
gonna be really fun because I've picked
out some really cool stuff for the rest
of the year
really cool IJ stuff we've got themed
boxes so I can't wait for you guys to
see them I'm gonna be doing some fun
contests and some little giveaways and
fun things around all of you guys who
get them or want to get them but now
I've got to finish packing or my parents
are going to leave me here last couple
of years they have left me but it's only
because I was in LA and I couldn't make
it out for the fun family trip oh my
gosh how long do you think you're gonna
be going for three days mmm
four days and not many days so I got
smash brothers pre-ordered and now we're
picking a brie and I get to hold the
puppy all the way to that no I told them
all I could close my legs and you need
to get to lace no but he's a little oh
you guys sit close
Iphicles they want a puppy missed him so
much missed me so much I won't hold him
yep did he pee yeah
all right little piggy squirt up I think
you might've peed on my hand but no it
comes just a little late for the vet oh
and I pick so my mother one day three
looks like oh hey guys we're late for
the vet only but I can help the puppy
back here you know so I'm lookin autumn
on give shots cuz I can't be in a room
really hmm he will go in so I'm gonna go
in for you eh no idea where we're going
oh my gosh we gotta get matched what's
wrong you sleepy
what's he want I know he might be a
longer he didn't do much just morning
I think you're thirsty you had a little
bit to drink already peed it out on your
face
I can't even stand that the cuteness is
overwhelming I want just stole him from
me lucky he's not crying
Oh cuz you're holding him
you don't like beyond like a baby or up
under your chest a little tongue always
yawning Wow he says you don't want to go
to the vet do you continue continue on
Hartman run road for three more I guess
so I think we're almost there
Oh show me you very much other a little
better legs in the back oh that's
brilliant okay you so big not so
somebody can get their shots now yeah I
don't know what's Charlotte ah he's
gonna get your vet shots no you can't
drink I go get me a little chunk Bri
it's gonna be or you gonna be okay very
mer all you didn't eat it Lynch good job
I don't want to leave him can you come
with us come to play with us at the
cabin you can play Smash Brothers with
me I just rent I just forgot it I rented
it oh no baby
Oh or just we got a baby be careful
around the concrete don't tell Bree
don't tell Bree free don't feel guys
don't tell Bree oh my god
he's just like so cute well sorry
a couple guests we're a couple guests my
entire body is breaking out from being
in the event everyone was saying what
you seen aren't you allergic I'm like
yeah actually I'm allergic to animals
and Bill has been bothering me but it's
the kitties that really do me in them
you know
Faden for showers Smash Brothers I need
you come out try just open it right here
no the electronics place and like you
have to check out if you buy a game or
anything and I'd smash brothers in a bra
and I was like you know what I'm just
gonna I'm not gonna make you miss your
man check out my bra just check out the
game I'm in levels what do you think of
this I'm not your mother figured
it out
oh he wants to be left alone oh my god
this is so weird one
here I need to find this out bird
episode
like God
I'm finding this you will love ah
free thank you she sweet so we made it
to the cabin I actually didn't even film
anything yesterday so we're here and
that brings me to the end of the vlog so
I'll see you guys tomorrow
for whatever we do today you can see the
house tour and everything on my blog
yeah certainly
um blah did you really yeah where was I
at not my home
[Music]